from Paragould Arkansas starting at the
bride position please welcome Ellen
[Music]
[Applause]
Ellen
[Music]
from Dallas starting at the officiant
position Mark Falwell
we're gathered here tonight in holy
matrimony
to join Reed and Ellen and the union of
marriage
basketball brought Reed and Ellen
together and it provides sound examples
of what makes a successful marriage
the individual must sacrifice for the
good of the team
and when one member of the team has a
bad day a teammate Picks Them Up and
supports them
the Hall of Fame coach Phil Jackson said
the strength of the team is each
individual member the strength of each
individual member is the team
and while basketball gives us a template
for marriage the most important
ingredient is your love for one another
Hall of Fame coach Vince Lombardi said
love is loyalty love is teamwork love
respects the Dignity of the individual
this is the strength of any team
and now to officially become a team
Reed do you take Ellen to be your wife
do you promise to love honor cherish and
protector forsaking all others and
holding only unto her forevermore
I do
and Ellen
do you take Reed to be your husband do
you promise to love honor cherish and
protect him forsaking all others and
holding only unto him forevermore
I do
the Rings please
[Applause]
Reed and Ellen well now Exchange rings
as a symbol of love and commitment to
each other
it is the Seal of the vows you have just
taken to love each other Without End
now please place the rings on each
other's hands and repeat after me
as a sign of my love
that I have chosen you that I have
chosen you
Above All Else Above All Else
with this ring with this ring Ivy Wood
ivy
by the power vested in me and with 20
000 NFLs as Witnesses
it's my delight to declare you husband
and wife read you may kiss the bride
Mass fans please welcome read and Ellen
oh
[Applause]